the only two things you have the only
thing you have to think about when
building a business around your passion
is what do you need not what you're
hoping for because if you figure out
what you need you got your prospective
[Music]
I'm probably followed I'm probably
following the tracks of my life I'm
probably right now disproportionately my
mom and sooner than later I'll be more
like my dad much like what I went
through which is the first fourteen
years of my life was only mom and then
the next you know kind of 15 years of my
life was heavily dad my dad did things
for me that actually allowed me to be
the Enigma that I am for somebody who is
such a self-promoter
gift of gab sizzle gun I'm convinced
which is tough to say out loud that the
things I most despise in people with
charisma I actually am and that the
parenting is what did it that I was
willing to lie to sell and that would
have manifested as me with girls and
that would have manifested me with
product and I know this because I did it
cuz at 14 and 15 I lied to sell wine I
just did like and so the fact that I got
lucky and came into a father who looks
at embellishment as a cardinal one
strike your if you embellish to my dad
if do you I'll call my dad and said
right now Sashi I'll never believe this
80,000 people just watch that clip and
the actual amount of people that watched
that clip was 78,000 my dad would never
trust e-rock again yeah
so think about I'm being serious think
about what I'm talking about yes we're
talking about extremity around so I went
from gift of gab [ __ ] what would some
people think I am when I first see
one-minute video to being suffocated
suffocated did you feel suffocated if in
a great way not at the time it was fear
I was fearful to embellish or lie to my
dad so it just started getting me into
practice to not which ironically had a
countercultural move to it made me not
to everybody else but but made me to him
ironically at times as well because I
didn't want to deal with the
ramifications of delusional suffocation
look I think it's the patients I [ __ ]
did for years every day of Wine Library
TV before anybody cared nobody watched
like I've only really blown up in the
last two or three years after doing it
really hard every day content of all
sorts mind and business for 10 years
it's just a matter of time the only
thing that the two of you have to figure
out is you know what if any financial
needs not aspirations this is a game of
meeting not hoping you know of course we
want you guys the three of you to make a
million dollars a year in advertising
and affiliates and merchandise like of
course you would want your you for sure
I don't want to impose what you guys are
so young you stuff to figure out how
much this has to be or not be or
whatever but like of course but the only
two things you have the only thing you
have to think about when building a
business around your passion is what do
you need not what you're hoping for
because if you figure out what you need
and you can make it happen well then you
can wait for what you're hoping for
because you love it that's it that will
take the pressure out of growth which
will lead you to cry less I mean it so
whether that means you're whether that
means you're providing whether that
means you come up with some whether that
means upfront
you guys are like no we need another
that we need which doesn't you know and
leading gets real interesting like
there's a lot of people are so miserable
would dream about doing a Disney podcast
yet they go to Wegmans to buy all their
food instead of maybe going to shop
right and in that $89 a week savings is
their opportunity that's how I really
believe it you know and so like there's
a lot of things you guys think our needs
that aren't in providing for them and
providing for yourself when you're doing
this big of a passion project I really
think you'll win I really do
I believe it I just think it takes a lot
of time and in that three to four years
where you have to give up stuff is where
people fail
[Music]
just on
[Music]